yo what's up its your boy Joey Souls aka
fancy footwork aka sneaker Pete aka the
deadstock Don as you know I love air
jordans and today we're checking out the
rarest of the rare Jace I'm talking
about the Holy Grails this is sneaker
boss
[Music]
I'm here in bed-stuy Houma biggie smalls
jay-z
and Panera Bread store 287 it's also
home of two of the biggest Jordan
collectors on the planet I'm talking
about the Dulles brothers yo a little
birdie told me you've got some sneakers
on there a little birdie was correct
tweet tweet come inside this castle come
on we got J everywhere you got shoes
shoes USB cables Shawn these shoes
though shows nations no these shoes
those shoes these shoes you want some a
drink sparkling water or maybe some OJ
or possibly some SNL sixes
they designed after the jacket Michael
Jordan wore when he hosts his sad not
live in 1991 one of its strongest cast
no live from New York I'm linking these
Souls baby now look I don't want to hate
but I know a lot of people have the SNL
sixes I want you to show me some real
geek come on that's a good point you
might be hungry to cook them up
something you hungry oh those candidates
as we all know MJ has a reputation for
being a notorious gambler
so the gambling debt ates honor all of
that it's got the dice the 13 the poker
chip turn it around boom it's the
commemorative golf club now people say
MJ lost over a million dollars on a 10
day golf vendor in the 90s allegedly and
when you pull the lever what happens BAM
baseball cleats we all know why we all
know why is dude you can't say that for
legal reasons yo these joints are a
hole-in-one guys those are great but I
need to see some of that dhola's magic
Joel - 25 these are in honor of the
Hanes commercial where Michael Jordan
thought he was so famous he could rock a
Hitler mustache boy they're like hey you
ain't Charlie Chaplin check this out
right here on the tongue we have the
Fuhrer stache let me comb that out for
you blood out let me see the soul oh
snap it's Hitler dunking on Winston
Churchill fam yeah it was his darkest
hour war is based on true story my
cousin told ya
look I don't want to be sacrilegious but
show me the Grail I think you had enough
yeah I think you want to see the Zola's
Brothers Grails you don't want that
magic yeah you don't want yeah and then
they see it this is the matrix give me
the red pill I'm ready to go okay here
we go ready go for bed-stuy
[Applause]
I
oh that's the craziest I've
ever seen in my life those are the
cry-face 20 please
oh my god I never thought I'd see these
in real life MJ had every single pair
destroyed there's some sort of like pump
action yeah right here young that's not
water dog those are real tears and so
are these you see dead no he's gonna be
like that for like an hour
yo sneakerheads that episode was dope
special shout out to the dhola's
brothers for hooking your boy up with
some very special edition Home Alone
fives choo-choo
[Music]